PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
So today we're
going to take a look
at a problem with
partial fractions,
and specifically how to
use these partial fractions
to compute Laplace inverses.
So just as a
warm-up, we're asked
to recall what the formula is
for the Laplace transform of f
prime, in terms of the
Laplace transform of f.
In the second part,
we're asked to find
the inverse Laplace transform
for three different functions.
The first one is 1
over s squared minus 4,
s squared divided by
s squared plus 4, e
to the minus 5s divided
by s squared minus 4.
And notice how none
of these functions
appear in the look-up table
for Laplace transform.
So in each case, we have
to use partial fractions
to convert it or massage
these functions into something
which we do know the Laplace
transform inverse for.
And then lastly, for
the third problem
we're asked to write
down the partial fraction
decomposition of this
function, 1 over s
squared times s squared plus 4
times s plus 1 times s plus 3.
And specifically, when we do the
partial fraction decomposition,
we're just going to leave
the undetermined coefficients
unknown.
We're not actually
going to solve for them.
OK?
So I'll let you think
about this problem.
And I'll be back in a moment.
Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
OK.
So for part one,
we're just asked
to recall the Laplace
transform of f prime in terms
of the Laplace transform of f.
So the Laplace
transform of f prime
we can write down as s times the
Laplace transform of F, which
I'll use capital F, minus
f evaluated at the lower
bound of the Laplace transform
integral, which in this case
is just zero minus.
OK.
So this is just part one.
This is a warm-up problem.
For part two,
we're asked to find
the inverse Laplace transform
for three different functions.
The first one is 1
over s squared minus 4.
And we see here that we can
factor the denominator into 1
over s minus 2 times 1 over s
plus 2, which means that we can
use a partial fraction
decomposition which
has the form of A
divided by s minus 2
plus B divided by s plus 2.
And then we need to solve
for the coefficients A and B.
So one way to solve
for the coefficients
A and B is just to multiply
both sides of this equation
through by the factors
s minus 2 and s plus 2.
We can then plug in values
of s and solve for A and B.
There's another way,
which is sometimes
referred to a cover-up method.
And in this case,
what we do is we pick,
for example, say
one of the places
where the denominator blows up.
So for example, if we look
at this factor s minus 2,
this factor diverges
when s approaches 2.
So then what we do is we go
back to our original function,
we cover up the term s minus
2 where it diverges, and then
in the remaining term, we
plug in the value of s which
causes the factor s
minus 2 to diverge.
So in this case, s
minus 2 diverges at 2.
So we would cover this
factor up and then plug
in s is equal to 2.
And this would give us the
value of A. So for this problem,
A is equal to 1 over 2 plus
2, which is just 1 over 4.
For B, we look at plugging
in s equals negative 2.
So we cover up the
factor that diverges
in the original function.
Plugging in s equals negative
2 gives me negative 2
minus negative 2.
So B is just negative 4.
So this function is 1/4 1
over s minus 2 minus 1/4 1
over s plus 2.
And when we take the
inverse Laplace transform,
so the inverse Laplace transform
of 1 over s squared minus 4
is going to be 1 over 4-- the
inverse Laplace transform of s
minus 2 is e to the plus 2t.
The second factor is negative
1/4 e to the negative 2t.
And this concludes
the first problem.
For the second function,
we have s squared
divided by s squared plus 4.
So again, this function's
not in the correct form
to use a Laplace
transform look-up table.
But what we can do
is we can divide--
long division of polynomials--
the numerator out
by the denominator.
So when we do that we end
up with 1 minus 4 divided by
s squared plus 4.
So when we take the inverse
Laplace transform of s
squared divided by
s squared plus 4,
we're left with the inverse
Laplace transform of 1
minus the inverse
Laplace transform of 4
divided by s squared plus 4.
And if we use our
look-up table, we
know that the inverse
Laplace transform of 1
is the delta function.
Meanwhile, the inverse
Laplace transform
of some number
divided by s squared
plus 4 looks like, in
this case, sine of 2t.
Now we need a 2 upstairs,
so this is going
to give us 2 times sine of 2t.
And I obtain this by noting that
the Laplace transform of sine
omega*t is equal to omega
divided by s squared plus omega
squared.
So that's how I went from
this function, this Laplace
transform inverse, to 2 sine 2t.
Lastly, for part three,
the third problem,
we're asked for the inverse
Laplace transform of e
to the minus 5s divided
by s squared minus 4.
Now note that we already know
the inverse Laplace transform
to 1 over s squared minus 4.
In this case, we're
just multiplying 1
over s squared minus 4
by e to the minus 5s.
So we can use the shift
formula in addition
to what we already computed,
the inverse Laplace transform
to 1 over s squared
minus 4, to compute
this inverse Laplace transform.
So the shift
formula says that we
need to multiply by the
step function t minus 5.
So we're shifting with
the step function.
And then what we do
is we want to shift
the inverse Laplace transform
of 1 over s squared minus 4.
So the inverse Laplace transform
to 1 over s squared minus 4
is 2 t minus 5.
So if we shift t by 5,
we end up with 1/4 e
to the 2 t minus 5 minus 1/4
e to the minus 2 t minus 5.
So again, just to
reiterate, when
we have an exponential
e to the minus, say, 5s
and we already know the inverse
Laplace transform of everything
else, we just multiply
by the step function u
t minus 5, the same shift.
And then wherever we see
the t in the inverse Laplace
transform, we just replace it
with t minus 5, in this case.
OK?
And now lastly, for
part three we're
just asked to write down the
decomposition for this very
large function, the partial
fraction decomposition
of this large function.
So it's s squared times
s squared plus 1 times
s plus 1 times s plus 3.
Let me just double
check. s squared plus 4.
OK?
And unfortunately
this function's
going to be a little ugly.
We're going to have a constant,
A, divided by s plus B divided
by s squared.
So these first two terms come
from this term right here.
For the s squared
plus 4 term, we're
going to seek a C
times s plus D--
so we need both factors,
Cs plus D-- divided by
s squared plus 4.
We have E divided by s plus 1.
And then plus F
divided by s plus 3.
So just to associate each
factor in the partial fraction
decomposition with
the original function,
I've just drawn some arrows.
OK?
And then lastly,
although I didn't
state this in the
original problem,
we can also just write down
the inverse Laplace transform
of this entire mess
without actually
determining the constants.
We can just keep
the constants in.
So if we wanted to compute
the inverse Laplace transform,
well, it would just be A--
because inverse Laplace
transform of 1 over s is
1-- plus B-- inverse Laplace
transform of s
squared is t-- plus,
now this part has two terms,
Cs divided by s squared plus 4.
That's going to give us
C times cosine of 2t.
The D divided by s squared plus
4 is going to give us, well,
we need to multiply upstairs by
2 and divide downstairs by 2.
So we get D divided
by 2 of sine 2t.
This term, E, is going
to give us E times
the exponential of negative t.
And then the last term is
going to give us F times e
to the minus 3t.
OK?
So just as a quick
wrap-up, in this problem
we've computed partial
fraction decompositions
of several functions.
And the reason we've done
this is because we often
end up in a situation when
we want to solve an ODE using
Laplace transforms where we
have some complicated function
and we need to use partial
fraction decomposition to write
down simpler functions,
in which case
we can then use the Laplace
inverse formula on each
of the simpler functions.
OK?
So I'll just conclude here,
and I'll see you next time.